[Music]
our story starts sometime ago on the
planet tattooing
obi-wan is on the run
nowhere to be seen
haunted by the ghosts of passing hunted
by the sith
a new adventure awaits our man so why
don't you come with but be warned there
will
be spoilers
buckle up
and follow me
[Music]
obi-wan was number one but for now he's
just his hero
spending his time cutting chunks of meat
but he'll soon return a hero
a princess captured one he swarmed to
protect
[Music]
he tries to save her but gets completely
wrecked
way way back on mustafar a padawan he
lost later searches for revenge you
don't care about the cost and will use
trench coats
to hide us
[Music]
it's not completely suss
obi-wan was number one but for now he's
just a zero
spending his time cutting chunks of meat
but he'll still return a hero
[Music]
a strong new ally
third sister's revenge
now
her story
hands
[Music]
obi-wan was number one but for now he's
just a zero
spending his time cutting chunks of meat
but he'll soon return a hero
[Music]
our final chapter ends with a duel
involving rocks
vader's helm is torn off got a busted
voice box
with luke and leia saved toby goes back
to seclusion
now for fans to argue what to think of
this conclusion only nine
more years
till new hope
then you'll look like
[Music]
was this one but for now he's just a
zero
spending his time cutting chunks of me
but will soon
return
[Music]
hello there
what's up guys this is my first time
ever doing a music video if you want
more of these for upcoming shows like
marvel star wars or the rings the best
thing you can do is like share it on
your socials and comment what series
you'd like to see next may the force be
with you